when that tiny alien burst out of John
hurt's chest and alien it scared
everyone including the cast
[Music]
actor John Hurt was taken aside during
shooting and rigged up to a device
loaded with pig organs then the rest of
the cast was brought in unaware of the
device about to spray them with pig guts
so when the next take left them all
covered in blood their faces expressed
true terrified surprise in one of
prometheus's more Infamous scenes a
biologist tries petting the world's
scariest space cobra
that's just regular old acting but when
his friends stumble across his body
later they get a real surprise
that time the screams were genuine to
pull the scene off director Ridley Scott
replaced the actor with a dummy loaded
the alien puppet in its mouth and
connected the alien creature to a wire
that a crew member pulled at the right
moment